it's still strange how a story like
Stephen King's it became such a big deal
but just because something is popular
doesn't mean it's good much less perfect
here's our list of the highlights and
lowlights and yes the deadlights of it
chapter 2
Oklahoma's favorite son Bill Hader has
really been showing off his dramatic
chops in recent years from his
critically adored turn in HBO's complex
berry to his work in it chapter 2 as the
grown up Richie Tozier in the sequel the
trashmouth has grown from a neighborhood
nuisance to a national sensation or at
least something like that as an
apparently well-known stand-up comic in
his role as the older Richie hater
builds on everything that stranger
things spin wolfhard
laid down for the character in Chapter
one so much so that it takes no effort
to believe that he's that kid just 27
years older the movie suggests that
despite any appearance of material
success he's not living up to his full
potential an intriguing step-up from the
radio DJ role he played in Kings book
with the writing for the character also
being a notable step up from the limp
improvised jokes Harry Anderson strung
together for the 1990 miniseries see my
fortune now you're gonna be eaten by a
big greasy monster despite what
successes it chapter two may have in
improving on the old miniseries reviews
have had one pretty consistent complaint
the grown-up members of the losers Club
don't really feel like old friends they
all feel more like they're meeting each
other for the first time and it's an
impression that never really goes away
and before you go pointing out that the
group members being distant towards each
other was the whole point of the movie
with it all culminating in the
characters reconnecting and learning to
love one another again we would like to
counter by saying that at no point in
this movie does it actually feel like
these people are really connecting with
each other
everyone is frigid and chilly towards
each other up until the point that they
have to wrench the heart out of an
ancient cosmic horror when they all
fight on the same side because well
that's what you're supposed to do one of
the biggest strengths of the first it is
the palpable sense of camaraderie that
can be felt when the young cast is all
interacting sparks are flying in these
scenes as are so so many f-bombs the kid
scenes in the sequels still crackle with
nostalgic energy while the grown-up
sequences all proceed as though their
dialogues among
strangers killing time at the DMV
despite those complaints don't get us
wrong in Chapter two has assembled a
fantastic cast seemingly willed into
existence by Twitter posts and fan
casting the sequel triumphantly nails a
difficult task while making it look
pretty easy casting the same part across
generations it's one of those things
that you don't really notice unless it's
done in a way that doesn't really work
that well in the its sequel does it so
seamlessly that it even stops to flex
about it emphasizing the similarities
between James ransom and Jack dough and
grazer as Eddy casts Brack in a show-off
you transition shot the new cast appeal
isn't all about physical resemblance
James McAvoy deploys an American accent
so convincing that you never question
his characters main upbringing and he
also conveys the perfect level of
frustration with his returning vocal
stutter Jay Ryan somehow manages to come
off as an adult Ben Hanscom one who
seems to be aware of how hot he's become
an adult hood but knows he's supposed to
be cool about it
even Andy bean in his brief turn as the
adult Stan URIs manages to make his few
scenes resonate by finding the right way
to express existential terror without
coming across as too melodramatic so
even though the cast members rarely seem
like real childhood friends they do all
come off as real people in their roles
perhaps one reason why the cast has no
chemistry is the fact the movie
explicitly demands they stop spending
time together at a critical point during
their reunion after returning to Derry
the group is told by Mike to split up to
recover relics from their childhood by
themselves the middle of the movie
follows them all as they go off on their
own specific side missions like it's the
end of a video game and we need one last
fetch quest before taking on the final
boss this plotline of needing to gather
relics for the ritual of Chad is mostly
an invention of the movies which
stretches to come up with a good reason
for the characters to spend time apart
as a result we end up spending way too
much of the movie watching the
characters be isolated facing their
fears in an assembly-line fashion that
gets dull fast logically the characters
would probably want to stick together
after realizing what Mike's told them is
all real and they're fighting a vengeful
demon whom they only beat the first time
by sticking together instead the movie
invents the reason for them to
arbitrarily split up not really because
the story demands it but more because
the screenplay structure does
one of the reasons why the cast lack of
chemistry is so frustrating has to do
with the one scene with them all
together that the movie 100% nails the
initial reunion sequence at the Jade of
the Orient Chinese restaurant in Kings
book this scene is less of a fun hangout
sequence and more of an exposition
engine playing track for the plot to
come in the 1990 miniseries version of
the scene is just weird feeling very
awkward and made-for-tv but it chapter 2
brings the scene to life with an
electric energy with the memories of the
losers Club seeming to come back in real
time as the protagonists loosen up both
through their renewed proximity to each
other and the curative powers of alcohol
the only place where this scene doesn't
improve on the old miniseries or the
book is the climactic invasion of it as
a bowl of demented fortune cookies which
jump up off the table and turn into CGI
monstrosity x' that kind of all look
like the horror movie equivalent of the
sonic trailer one of the most consistent
Sens of it chapter 2 aside from its over
reliance on jump scares and loud noises
is the overuse of way too much not quite
there CGI during the movies horror
sequences it almost feels like the movie
overloads on creepy music and startling
monster leaps of the screen moments to
make up for the fact that on its own a
lot of the CGI stuff just isn't scary
CGI creature effects work best in
something like a light-hearted Avenger
style movie when you want to buy into
the comic book fiction of it all and let
the movie get away with things that look
less than realistic but that's generally
not how things work with horror which
gets its most effective scares out of
keeping the viewer engaged and drawing
them into a nightmarish moment making
them believe if even for just a second
that everything they're seeing is real
when a supposedly horrific sight makes
you think more about what's new on Xbox
than the fact that you're gonna die one
day
it makes the scares much less effective
and the movie therein less capable of
standing the test of time that said
don't get us wrong there are parts of
each chapter to in which the horror all
really works critics have said that
chapter 2 is less scary than its 2017
predecessor and while this may be true
by the time the losers Club is fighting
penny wise as a giant spider and
defeating
by screaming the f-word it's not really
true for the entire movie indeed some
sequences in the sequel shiver with such
horror that they trounce anything the
first movie put forward as a scare
despite all the child slayings the first
it movie had a tendency to feel more
like a thrill ride than anything close
to being psychologically effecting
that's not the case for some of it
chapter two's most genuinely disturbing
scenes which include the vicious assault
and killing of a young gay man at the
beginning of the movie
- penny wise sickly manipulating and
devouring a little girl underneath some
dairy bleachers the real horror should
do more than just startle you
it should make you feel nasty and stick
to you like a greasy slime penny wise
sleeping out of the dark with his claws
out might make you jump while you're
watching the movie but these are the
sequences that stick with you in the
nights that follow of course there's a
lot to remember about it chapter 2 once
you're done watching it mostly because
this sequel is a lot of movie like too
much movie at 165 minutes the sequels
runtime edges up toward Avengers end
game levels but that movie was MCU
chapter 22 not oh - it's a long story
well the movie doesn't feel truly
punishing and it's length on a first
watch it does feel every minute of its
long length and it doesn't really feel
like an experience that digs deep enough
into its themes or characters to really
warrant that massive runtime so much of
the movie is given over to catching the
audience up on where the characters are
out in their lives and then giving them
each a protracted solo scare sequence a
structure that gets repetitive and
tiresome well before the final battle
comes around you can say a lot of things
about Stephen King but one thing you
can't deny is that the dude has a big
imagination potent eerie too hot for TV
imagination to the tune of 1138 pages of
often insane storytelling as a book it
is full of rich details and left-turn
sequences that seem inspired at least in
part by a lenient editor and a lot of
cocaine for me the fun of writing novels
isn't in the finished product which I
don't care about that much it's to the
credit of each chapter to that the
sequel incorporates so many of the
novel's weirdest elements making the
already strange story of a
shape-shifting killer Klown
even weirder this time around though the
two it movies leave plenty of the more
bizarre elements of Kings story out of
the adaptation it's admirable just how
much Corning craft a movie commits to
getting into especially when it doesn't
really need to explain too much about
what's going on in Derry at all once the
movie starts running through weird
things like the ritual of chug and it's
true form as the cosmic deadlights you
know you're watching a movie with some
goofball genre swagger this is a story
that trusts you to stay with it through
every weird turn up to and including the
part where the losers kill penny wise by
basically just hurting its feelings
though it Chapter two is willing to go
to some strange places when it comes to
its ancient cosmic origins the movie
doesn't exactly go hold hog with
everything the book has to offer and
we're not just talking about the novel's
space turtle know there are plenty of
other story aspects from Kings thick
novel that just don't get a lot of play
here from the way the mere presence of
it is implied to bring out the evil in
dairies residents to the wider lives of
the grown up losers whose loved ones
play more into the resolution of the
story in the book than the movie wants
to get into when other notable loss is
the instantly abandoned storyline at the
grown-up Bev's abusive husband who was
given one scene to be a bad guy before
Bev flees this entire aspect of her life
and character remains totally unresolved
and it speaks to a general lack of
thematic storytelling in its second
installment if the first movie was about
childhood and loss of innocence the
second movie is about what exactly for
all its length and bluster it chapter
two isn't really about anything other
than killing that clown check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]